bonjour Théodore bonjour tu
as un rendez-vous dans cinq minutes tu veux
essayer de sortir du lit Oh trop drôle
[Musique]
hé d'Or je signe tes emails que tu as
vécu une rupture récemment tu es
plutôt curieux Am  Je, tu t'y habitueras
[Musique] bon
sang, qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être marié, il y
a quelque chose qui fait du bien de
partager sa vie avec quelqu'un,
comment partage-t-on sa vie avec quelqu'un, dis-
moi la vérité, ce n'est pas la jambe de
la femme que je'  J'ai vu Samantha, c'est
un système d'exploitation avec qui tu sors
en un clin d'œil et qu'est-ce que c'est ? Je me sens
vraiment plus proche quand je lui parle, j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est avec moi, j'apprends
tout sur tout ce que je veux
me découvrir, je veux ça pour  tu
continues à tomber amoureux c'est un peu
comme une forme de folie socialement acceptable
tu sors avec un ordinateur ce n'est pas seulement
un ordinateur tu as toujours voulu avoir une
femme sans les défis de
faire face à quelque chose de réel et heureux d'avoir
trouvé quelqu'un
Je veux toujours assez de mon éjaculation sans fin
pour une vraie relation, n'est-ce pas une vraie
relation
[Musique]
Je peux ressentir la peur que tu portes
avec toi
J'aimerais qu'ils puissent t'aider à lâcher prise
parce que je ne pense pas que tu ressentirais ça
plus seul tu es belle
[Musique]
nous ne serons là que brièvement et pendant que je suis
là, je veux me permettre d'écrire je
n'ai jamais aimé personne comme je t'aime,
sais-tu comment
tu es